madame monsieur les 12 et 19 juin
prochain auront lieu les élections
législatives ces élections sont très
importantes
après l'élection d' emmanuel macron ce
sont elles qui décideront de la
politique qui sera mené dans notre pays
pour les cinq prochaines années nous
avons la chance de vivre sur un
territoire exceptionnel
mais rien n'est jamais acquis avec vos
mères je m'impliquerai fortement dans la
préservation de notre environnement et
la défense de l'attractivité et la
tranquillité de nos communes avec le
soutien de philippe cochet maire de
caluire et cuire et ancien député de
cette circonscription et de laurent
wauquiez président de notre région
auvergne rhône-alpes je suis le candidat
qui défend les valeurs qui nous
rassemblent le travail le mérite la
responsabilité la liberté d'entreprendre
la famille et la solidarité pour ceux
qui en ont vraiment besoin
madame monsieur je suis bastien juin
élus de caluire et cuire et les 12 et 19
juin prochains je compte sur vous notre
territoire mérite vous méritez un député
qui vous soit vraiment utile qui votent
chaque loi en fonction de l'intérêt de
chacune et chacun d'entre vous avec
votre confiance je serai le député du
renouveau un député de proximité un
député à votre écoute un député
disponibles un député qui rassemble sans
parti pris je compte sur vous
[Musique]